الصوره ايضا تتحدث الان يبدو بان هناك
اطلاق
لصواريخ القذائف من القبه الحديديه على ما
يبدو
نشاهد الصوره اذا من غزه نحن في الدقيقه
التاسعه
من الساعه التي دخلت فيها اتفاقيات وقف
اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ
والصوت والصوره
نشاهدها ونستمع اليها
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى الياس كرام انت معنى الياس من
عسقلان ما الذي يجري
نعم بالفعل سلمى وكانت هنالك دفعه من
الصواريخ التي استهدفت المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه تحديدا منطقه
يد مردخاي وقد شاهدنا بالفعل دفعه من
الصواريخ التي كانت ايضا في مقابلها
صواريخ القبه الحديديه التي اعترضتها
وكانت هنالك ايضا في الدقائق الاخيره يعني
في الدقيقه السابعه بعد دخول وقف اطلاق
النار حيز التنفيذ ايضا صافرات انذار دوت
في منطقه كيسوفيم في وسط قطاع غزه يبدو ان
هنالك ايضا كان قصف صاروخي وحقيقه بان هذا
غريب نوعا ما بان تطلق المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بعد الساعه العاشره
دفعه جديده من الصواريخ بعد دخول وقف
اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ